this team it's gonna go to sokovia
they're gonna battle the ghosts of
Ultron he's going to find a little
something cold evil Weapon X program
everything is building towards the next
Avengers new rock stars this is rogue
theory and something must have gone
horribly wrong because our first second
third all the way through 57th choices
to host could it make it today and
that's why me
your good friend Thomas Michael Beck
told us here today we're gonna get a
little bolder with the Falcon and Winter
Soldier later we'll be doing a little
casting flex with our men and women of X
I'm Tommy Bechtel and we're going rogue
remotely with with many good friends of
ours first of all we've got the boss
Erik Voss oh the boss is ready yeah all
right she's far from done writer and
podcaster Ashley V Robinson most about
your mom oh wait I'm Canadian so I got a
show I love it and our friend empty he
makes our heart go pitter pitter you
know I miss master Taemin on YouTube and
Twitter give it up for empty everybody
welcome back and guess what I am still
black so what a shocking river what a
shocking revelation if you weren't so
here we go
topic number one Falcon and Winter
Soldier Anthony Mackie has described the
upcoming season of the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier as a six episode movie
unlike any episodic series he or any of
the cast and crew have worked on before
maybe want to run that by the cast and
crew in case they've worked on I don't
know Watchmen Game of Thrones any of the
following series that have been on HBO
over the last 10 years several other
shows either way Mackie is uh he's a
groundbreaker here assuming the new
series will be a unified story like the
movies in Marvel's past phases endgame
civil war Winter Soldier etc I want you
guys to pitch me this series as the
latest Marvel film how will it be
sequel to Civil War or our Secret
Invasion prequel anything like that and
and secondarily I'd like you to explain
what's gonna be its big contribution to
the MCU there was that set photo of all
these guys like huddled in the snow
and I'm wondering well what setting have
we seen in the MCU that is in Eastern
Europe other than sokovia I think Falcon
when her soldier is gonna take us back
to the country of sokovia we're gonna
see a plot that deals with the aftermath
of Avengers age of Ultron so why would
you get Baron Zemo to be part of this
crew well he was a military ranger for
the sokovia
special ops that guy knows the territory
but what is the what's the problem here
what are they what is this crew working
together to solve well I've always
wondered what happened to Ultron there
were all these centuries that were
buzzing around there was that severed
century head that Peter Parker found
with the sentient red glowing eyes of
Ultron illuminated in its skull
suggesting that Ultron may still be
alive and well an algorithmic form
cosplaying as Arnim Zola perhaps in
sokovia there's like some psycho bein
engineer who gets his hands on an old
Ultron century not knowing that it
possesses Ultron's AI sentient AI plugs
it into his machine and in doing so
accidentally activates an Ultron
contingency plan he goes through the
internet tubes through the wires to a
nearby sokovia n-- power plant former
Soviet installation maybe we have some
kind of a fail-safe that had his first
plan failed we have a radiation leak
that it radiates the continent of Europe
Eurasia these are the whole world
Chernobyl scenario that is way harder to
prevent then you know just pulling a
chunk of the sokovia and city and
throwing it down to earth using gravity
that's terrifying
so Thunderbolt Ross gets wind of this
and he's like I gotta put together a
crew we got to put our differences aside
and I and I we got to get this freakin
helmet Zemo out of prison but I want my
guy I want my white Russell to get
credit for this so he's gonna be the
frontman of the
team but really I know I need Sam Wilson
and I need Bucky Barnes to manage this
freaking helmet Zemo so this crew also
maybe get a couple women on this team
you get Helen Cho in there
she knows the the ultra and Anatomy
better than anyone so this team is gonna
go to sokovia and have to put a lid on
this they're gonna battle old demons are
gonna battle each other and they're
gonna battle the ghosts of Ultron I'm
going to award something very special
instead of rogue ease today I'm going to
be awarding and guys this is a real
treasure for you
Tinseltown tommy's these are physical
copies of my first headshot talk about a
fall from grace this is a real
before/after that'll make you want to
move home so Eric for your theory which
I enjoy a little chore noble action a
little you son of a [ __ ] we're getting
a team together action some a team some
Chernobyl I like you I'm giving you is
the words of the chorus light ad from
2002 featuring Kid Rock twins I'm giving
you two and you can tell me what those
become on your end Eric they become a
black in the silver sparkle box give it
no more okay very good what a good start
we're off to you guys who's next I'll go
next so the thing that we know about
especially the last Captain America
centric movie was that it was actually
an Avengers movie civil war is not a
Captain America story it is a Avengers
story so I think that this long and
maybe protracted film that that's what
we want to call this is actually going
to be more about building the next
generation of Avengers because ever
since we had the very first Avengers
team every MCU property project is
building towards the next Avenger so I
think that the first half will probably
draw directly from Despenser's Captain
America run although that wouldn't be my
preference because it does deal directly
with a bunch of evil white people not
liking
person of color being Captain America
and I hope that were past that so
instead what I hope they actually do is
we move right to building the next
generation and we go full Young Avengers
though all of my theories are just gonna
be things that I want to have happen cuz
that's how Ashley rolls and Young
Avengers a Children's Crusade is so
perfect and it's so amazing for
something like this and it would tie
directly into one division and in one
division we have rumors that we've seen
Evan Peters as Quicksilver show up so we
could start laying the groundwork for a
Secret Invasion type story because even
in the comics and MCU lifts Oh usually a
name only from the comics one of the big
reveals of who is a scroll is Pietro we
also know that one division is going to
introduce the twins Billy and Tommy
because we've seen the twin pacifiers
we've seen the twin teddy bears and all
the background information and they are
two of the founding members of The Young
Avengers so they're probably not gonna
focus in Captain America or Falcon
Winter Soldier as heavily but what can
we do in Falcon Winter Soldier we can
introduce to potential members of a new
Avengers team Miss America who in some
incarnations on alternate universes like
in Spider Gwen's universe actually has
the Captain America shield or Samantha
Wilson is Captain America and we could
introduce our version of Kate Bishop
Hawkeye so I think what we're gonna do
because this is the first of the
television shows not only is this going
to be laying groundwork for future
stories on television it's going to be
laying groundwork for future films
building up this new Avengers team
there's also room on a potential new
Avengers or Young Avengers team to
introduce Miss Marvel who we know is
getting her own television series down
the line if Black Widow ever comes out
when Black Widow comes out whatever
that's going to look like
we have Florence pews Yelena Bulova
stepping up to fill that spy role and
she would be such an amazing addition as
a young Avengers version to join this
show because Black Widow and Winter
Soldier have a working and
sometimes romantic relationship in the
comic books now that's traditionally not
but considering that yalena Bulova in
the marvel max series is mostly known
for her lingerie Empire I have a feeling
that we're going to be taking a lot more
from some of Nats storylines then maybe
we initially thought about so I think
the first half of its going to be Bucky
and say I'm having to set their
differences aside to come together to
build this young Avengers team maybe
with Children's Crusade undertones which
is their first big outing into the world
and maybe maybe we'll get some Secret
Invasion well a lot of information I
Young Avengers signed me up I love the
idea of this planting of even in concert
or in congruence with Wanda vision
planting the seeds of Young Avengers the
next step of Avengers I think that's a
would be a brilliant move yeah I think
this theory does you said a lot about
the twins being a part of this and I
reward you two twins that's gonna look
like a defiant and a Phoenix I have four
tiny Star Trek ships on my desk so
that's what we're playing with my side I
love it and last but not least mr. M
Chee this is about to get some really
why and really great
Zemo right now zimos in prison and Zemo
is probably upset via vendors are back
together since after Civil War he was
like yeah I did it I split up the
Avengers and I was like Oh panels
brought them all together great thank
you purple man really really nice of you
so I think that Zemo is going to get a
nice little mysterious email from
somebody letting him know that there
a resource of available to him that
nobody knows about
so he's gonna break out of prison and
he's going to find a little something
called the Weapon X program with with a
Wolverine in stasis ready to be released
and also a Jessica drew spider woman who
used to be a Hydra agent at one point
before she became a superhero so I feel
like we're going to see the introduction
of mutants and Jessica drew who is a
mutant but with this Weapon X program in
that uh Sam and Bucky are going to try
to stop
Zemo from releasing more Hydra super
agents while this mysterious email
person is actually Zola and he's like
hmm I'm actually using Zemo to rebuild a
Hydra some house oh that is my theory on
what might happen to care achter that I
most often on rogue theory accidentally
call each other so that is perfect I
know yeah maybe they'll get married and
just tie it all up yeah what would their
ship name be soul emo Zoli moe I love it
Netta causal mo speaking of shipping two
of my favorite things together I'm gonna
ship these to Tinseltown Tommy's and
send them your way empty because you my
friend have won two gorgeous rookies and
how are they showing up on your end this
is actually okay got a slap
special Marvel edition number 15 which
is the first appearance of shame Wow
i luckily snagged this right before the
xiangjian faa came out very nice it's
still in its packaging as you can tell
and it's where my prides enjoys so thank
you miss excellent I love it all right
well traditionally at this point in the
show I asked you all to give your
theories back to me in the form of a
tweet and by traditionally I mean the
one other time that I hosted I did that
but I took that from the other host of
the show so if you could now one by one
individually give me your theories back
in bite-size form starting with Eric
please do you want it in a tweet or do
you want to invite I want in bite-size
form there's not why are you being
difficult you could have just taken the
vote this one all right just get back to
me in a tweet you sweetheart okay so
it's from the account of secretary Ross
you know William Hurt he's saying oh I'm
putting together a crew I'm gonna need
you at Sam Wilson cookie barns you at
helmet Zemo but he smells from it wrong
so it goes to some other guy who lives
in Cincinnati and he goes in and at you
at u.s. agent John Walker who's the
different John Walker one who you don't
want to tag in a tweet because he's got
some really unfortunate social media
manager and it just stays up for weeks
and all right Ashley so this comes from
at uatu the watcher and he says so happy
that at Falcon cap and at Winter Soldier
have put their differences aside to
become
boyfriends their adopted children at
Wicca at hulling at miss marvel at Miss
America and at speed are going to be the
best team ever with a little love it
alright um I'm gonna keep it short and
sweet this is already a very popular
hashtag already I'm hashtags le mo big
everyone everyone we mo Dex limo with
the that's all I'm sorry guys flattery
will get you everywhere I'm moving but
first let's talk about privacy everyone
sometimes our online research for new
rockstars videos takes us into some
questionable directions and let's be
honest my normal research takes me in
questionable directions so let's not
blame it on the job we've done entire
videos on the sexual history of the Hulk
spoiler alert he wrecks a lot of bed
frames and Emperor Palpatine whose
sexual desires many find to be unnatural
it's times like those but it doesn't
matter what mode you use or how many
times you clear your browsing history
your internet service provider can still
see every site you've ever visited like
a hovering mother watching you do your
homework judging you no comic books til
you're done with homework no YouTube
till you're done with homework that's
why whether at home or work we use
expressvpn
and bang mama can't hurt you then
expressvpn is an app that reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
servers so your isp can't see the sites
you visit expressvpn keeps all of your
information secure by encrypting 100% of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available not some weak
encryption that's only gonna hide some
of your data this [ __ ] throws an
invisibility cloak over it ok so march
through the halls of Hogwarts looking at
whatever you want
it runs seamlessly in the background
just tap one button bang you're
protected expressvpn is available on all
your devices phones computers even your
smart TV so if you got a Roku you're not
watching HBO max but you can use Express
via
so there's no excuse for you to not be
using it excuse protect your online
activity today with VPN rated number one
by C net and wired visit my exclusive
link VPN comm slash rogue and you can
get an extra three months free on a
one-year package by my math that's
fifteen months okay that's not twelve
that's a fifteen month year which is
about how long 20 20 fields
that's Express exp are e SS VPN dot-com
slash rogue expressvpn
dot-com slash rogue to learn more I love
you all very much I want to talk to you
guys about something I'm very passionate
about if you're an e-commerce seller
right now is a wild time that ship
station is here to help let me tell you
for the last five years I've tried to
set up an eBay store for my father
selling everything from pieces of glass
to rubber hoses the man keeps everything
it's worth noting however pivoting
shipstation can probably help you out
and here's why when new rock stars has
tried to ship things like merch in the
past it gets confusing figuring out what
is shipped and what hasn't and how much
it all costs let me tell you when you
ship the amount of thongs that we ship
out of you rock stars you got to be
organized they're so small they could
easily get lost most people order five
or six I'm wearing seven new rock stars
thongs right now ship station mind is
lost in the crack actually so I can't
find so it's gone it's just gone missing
presumed dead ship station helps online
sellers of any size get orders out
quickly save money on shipping costs and
keep their customers happy and at the
end of the day a happy customer is a
returning customer they'll get you your
shipping rates normally reserved for
fortune 500 companies okay you don't
have to be Eastman Kodak you don't have
to be hewlett-packard you don't have to
be any other struggling business right
now you can be your own little company
thriving in an unlikely economy what's
left what's right airlines are crashing
Nokia stock up through the roof with 5g
we don't know what's going on in the
markets anymore ship like a boss it's
the fastest easiest the most affordable
way to manage and ship your orders just
printing out labels and getting your
product to happy customers which as I
said is encouraged in business
to my knowledge chip station believe it
or not is the number one choice of
online sellers and I believe it
you'll ship more in less time with the
best rates available and right now
you're not gonna believe it there's a
deal we're offering you right now you
can try ship station free for 60 days
when you use the code rogue you don't
want your packages to go rogue you want
them to go where are you trying to send
them so use the code rogue don't use
rogue as a lifestyle with your shipping
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of delivery culture get
started at ship station calm today click
on the might of the phone at the top of
the homepage and type in rogue
that's ship station calm then enter the
offer code rogue ship station comm make
ship happen guys now it's time for the
discord rogue theory personal favorite
of mine I wreak havoc on discord all
week with nonsense but most people use
it for what it's intended for creating a
community where we can share and
exchange ideas every week we play a game
of rogue theory with our patrons on the
new rockstars discord and this week we
had some patrons pitch theories about
what Michael Keaton's Batman might end
up doing in the upcoming flash movie
which I am very very excited about side
note I felt like that was a bit of news
the world needed I don't even know if
it's gonna end up happening but like I
feel like people were like everybody's
really sad right now let's put Michael
Keaton in Batman again
just to cheer for it up so I'm with you
I will put on a bat suit which will not
be comfortable for me or anyone watching
and I will protest
okay so JB and Roxy had some great
theories but in the end it was our
patron Lewis Brown who won with his
theory
attaboy Lewis I won with his theory that
malaria is a sum of cyborgs tech to hop
between universes eventually landing in
Michael Keaton's where Keaton's Batman
acts as a mentor figure and the two of
them faced off against reverse reverse
reverse reverse flash and oh my god
sorry I didn't have any blood left in my
brain because I was so excited about
that theory you can play too and have
your theory read on an episode of rogue
theory by becoming a
patron of your rock star and joining our
discord God do we watch you in there
guys I share recipes pictures of dogs
yeah my innermost thoughts on the
discord you gotta get in there yeah and
just to give some love to Lewis here
that theory was really really well
thought out man like I loved how you
tied in reverse-flash in there I think
that was set up back in Justice League
when he was talking to his dad and you
know he's frame for you know murder
there I think it's alright they're ready
to pick back up and and I loved how you
tied in the the CW arrowverse Christ son
in front of an infinite earths event
where as a Remillard cameoed in there
like you tied it all together in a way
to where I read it I'm like oh yeah
that's that's I'm already the movie that
makes sense you could just print that
out and scrap for them and they'll be
good to go love it alright back to the
show just a quick update I did shower
too soon and I'm sweating through my
shirt as a result of not drying properly
second topic pick your returning x-men
we know at some point Marvel is gonna
bring back the x-men they simply must
okay the franchise loss team at Fox with
the Age of Apocalypse and Dark Phoenix
which I took my 9 year old nephew James
to and his response was I wish that was
better and when a nine-year-old says
that about a movie I don't know I guess
you just have to take that at face value
I mean he likes everything he likes
microwaved corn like that is a delicacy
to him and Dark Phoenix did okay however
the x-men are undeniably one of the most
popular and beloved superhero franchises
ever
and Marvel is not gonna let those sweet
babies go to go to waste so let's make
the reasonable assumption that we'll see
an x-men movie in the next five years
and the unreasonable assumption that
they'll have some actors play their
previous roles so with that I've decided
then we're gonna have a little fantasy
draft right now so we're gonna draft
x-men now the same way we would draft a
fantasy football team which is we're
gonna do a snake draft so how this will
happen is empty you'll draft first okay
Ashley the draft second Erik will draft
third then Erik will draft again and we
will snake back around and so on and so
forth so we're picking five five total
and we're gonna do five total rounds
and I will try my best to provide
analysis for each round and in the end
we'll evaluate our teams okay
so with that being said team down you
are on the clock with the first pick in
the 2020 x-men fantasy draft let us know
your pick well with this first pick it's
it's all over because I've already won
I'm gonna have to pick Briana hill of
Hildebrand's negasonic teenage warhead
because that girl is my girl I love her
number one pick number one pick did you
see did you see her Deadpool one and two
my girl is on fire she's shining and I
freaking love her Wow to day so that's
my girl negasonic that's a shocking
first-round pick guys the draft is
always full of surprises straight out of
high school for going her college career
negasonic teenage warhead going first in
the draft you really got to expect to
see everything here Ashley you are on
the clock with your first-round pick my
first-round pick is my favorite of all
potential x-men they were only in one
movie and the opening sequence of this
movie illustrates why they are
underrated in their power Alan [ __ ]
icon as Nightcrawler Kurt Schmoke knows
the incredible night kata the best x-men
who ever was and truly every time
there's an x-men movie I go please bring
Alan [ __ ] back
please pay him however much money he
wants to come back he's still great and
and I do do think he's very very
underrated so let's have him back with
more badass infiltration of government
property I think that's a really good
good first round pick and he can't be
that busy second second pick overall
Nightcrawler prospect from I believe
Germany right or is the Austrian I don't
know one of he's German excuse
tournament Eric we could do the accents
again probably shouldn't all right Eric
all right you guys are making it easy
for me for my first round route draft
I'm picking Hugh Jackman Wolverine
how could you pick anyone else the man
the myth the legend and you know what
since we're going around the horn here
who better to partner with him then Ryan
Ryan Reynolds Deadpool my god so excited
about that my phone fell over everything
went to hell here for a second yeah I
like that I like that a lot so Erik what
you did is we call this antiquing in the
fantasy football trade that's where you
select some old veterans so you know
what's better than one teleporter who's
really really powerful and iterated two
of them so my second pick is fan
bingbing as Blink from x-men Days of
Future past because one she's an
incredible actress who deserves more
work in the mainstream Hollywood like
machine I love her so much and I want
them to paint her pink I have her action
figure I seriously this is just my team
of freaking I'm in good shape your
thoughts all right well I mean I already
won with negasonic I guess well I'm
gonna have to say we're gonna have to go
with Quicksilver Evan Peters Quicksilver
my dude is fast my dude is cool my dude
knows how to infiltrate a facility or
two and he's just really awesome and
honestly I prefer him over the MCU
Quicksilver as everyone else does I
guess that's not really a controversial
opinion but since Pietro has kicked the
bucket
unfortunately I'm got Swiss cheesed by
Ultron he we beat another one so why not
Evan Peters again is rumored to be in
wand vision so I'm down to see some
goggled of teenage boy running around my
screen so that sounds very weird please
sure Evan Peters is like almost very
over mad I don't know why and you know
what I don't think there's anything
wrong with that we're just talking about
head care folks goggles their glasses
for underwater and they're not a spot
every every Digimon character with their
goggles on their well don't get too
comfortable because you are still on the
clock here so you have got the first
pick of round 3 well big mistake because
here it comes I'm gonna have to pick
Stefan Kappa six Colossus from the
Deadpool movies yes I got Jerry like
literally two losses from the Deadpool
movies is the way Colossus should have
been done from the beginning like that
era probably one of the most comic
accurate film comic book characters I've
ever seen like I loved him in the
Deadpool movies and he needs to be
directly imported into the MCU so
excellent I like it you know you need
that's like when a team drafts a massive
offensive lineman you know it's not the
sexiest thing but is it it's a pick
that's gonna give your team the power it
needs to establish a running game much
like when the Buffalo Bills
[Laughter]
I'm only reasonably sure that I know how
to pronounce this gentleman's name so if
somebody actually does know please feel
free to correct me
I want the x-men character who was done
the absolute dirtiest by the writers the
directors and the producers of any x-men
film and that is Eddie Gaddafi's Darwin
from x-men first class
because first of all wonderful
underrated actor who can a character who
can survive anything was their only
black character I mean I guess angel and
they murdered very badly so I think
again I've collected a bunch of
characters that I think have power sets
that were not effectively used and I
just think there's so much potential for
the character and the actor so I want
Darwin to come back and I want him to
lead a team I I co sign that hard yeah
thank our courses I love Darwin so much
all right Eric you're up all right so
I'm again going back to the older era
and my friends I don't care how many
stupid puns or jokes are bad line Halle
Berry may have said how do you kill a
toad lightning the same way everything
else to see it's so bad I can't even
remember but I love Halle Berry and I
want her to be my storm on my team I'm
taking Aurora Monroe from the first
x-men I think Halle Berry is great and
in my mind see when I became aware of
the x-men as a child it was the Fox
x-men animated series a where yeah where
Monroe was like 48 years old yes and to
see every word out of her mouth was a
dramatic monologue and I feel like Halle
Berry has now become the age where she
could destroy that character in the best
possible way do you want her to do the
questionable acts at work or the
American diet I just said I want Halle
Berry to try I want her to get some
lessons from Chadwick Boseman or
something on how do I get the accent
right cuz I let's go for it it's
terrible I have AB cool all right you've
got another pick yes for my other pick I
will take the character that I was most
excited to see for the future of the Fox
x-men franchise before it was sold off
to Disney
x-23 Laura new Wolverine
I think she's fantastic she's bilingual
she can do everything Wolverine does but
such this great partnership between the
two of them I I want to hear what
Deadpool has to say about her I want to
see what kind of wisdom Ororo Munroe can
pass down to her and I want to see what
surprises she's in store for these other
three old-timers this is my four and I
got a I got a fifth I hope that it isn't
picked away from me but it doesn't comes
back around well what are the surprises
she has is a knife in her foot that's
that's pretty big surprise
all right Ashley around four who is your
pick so if anyone watching doesn't know
this about me my very favorite thing in
the whole wide world is the Lord of the
Rings franchise and there have been two
actors from Lord of the Rings who played
x-men one of them is Magneto and then
the other one is Dominic Monaghan as
bolt from x-men origins Wolverine he's
another character they did super super
dirty he was supposed to play Beek who's
a way better character than bolt ever
thought about being but fine
he's bolt dominic monaghan they did him
dirty in Star Wars but he's also already
kind of under the Disney umbrella right
now so I think he'd be a great character
to bring back redeem and I don't really
have anybody with any sort of practical
real-world powers so electricity seems
like a good thing to have on like you I
now have two picks your fourth pick and
then your final pick okay well my fourth
pick another person that Fox kind of did
dirty in I believe x-men apocalypse a
lot of condors Jubilee I mean I've been
I was so excited when I heard that like
she was gonna get some play and they
didn't even get her she's even use her
powers I don't think like she was in the
movie but just nothing happened so like
I need my yellow coded Jubilee like fret
like literally go straight-up 90s like
full-on 90s with the look if the glasses
and everything I want that on screen
hardcore a lot of Condor is killing it
right now and she's a fantastic
actress so like just bring her in when
ass I'm cool I love it and your final
pick and my final pick I'm gonna have to
go with I'm gonna keep with keep it
light fiend and go with a Dazzler
for like two seconds but I love Dazzler
in general and she's just so cool and I
would love to see her in the MC all
right okay Ashley your final pick my
final pick is from x-men apocalypse out
which we haven't seen a lot of
representation of and that is going to
be Olivia Munn's Cylon because I think
Psylocke is super cool
I know Olivia Munn is like sometimes a
controversial pick in geekdom I think
she's a really great actress I would
encourage people to watch the newsroom
if you don't think that she's your cup
of tea she was such a good choice for
this and again had nothing to do silac
has gone on to be Captain Britain and to
lean more into the mythological aspects
that the name comes from and I just
think you could create a really cool
role for that character on a team and in
my lineup I didn't have a magic wielders
I love it
so now we get to the final pick in the
draft and traditionally in like
professional sports dress this is where
they will now pan the camera to all the
people who have not been drafted yet and
watch as they agonizing looks on their
face like I imagine a close-up on beasts
face as he's like what happened I was
told I would be drafted first round
Cyclops is on the phone with his agent
furiously complaining Jean Grey is
giving rogue a back rub saying it's okay
your time will come you know more morph
is still reeling being murdered in the
cartoon
I just got by morph action figure 4 page
apocalypse the corner shuffling a deck
of supercharged cards gambit goes come
on surely someone's got to pick the
gambit let's go you don't want reveal
above and Erik's is standing there with
the last rows like Erik oh so handsome
will be the final pick in this draft I'm
gonna money wallet and get my favorite
expert character really it's striker
thank you he will bring to the franchise
by having his his southern charm his
commanding presence he's he's gonna be a
great guy in the van the guy in the
chair he's gonna call the shots I mean
every x-men franchise needs an evil
white guy so yeah right they're gonna
flip him and he understands the ins and
outs of Weapon X better than anyone who
better than to lead a team of James
Howlett and Wade Wilson and x-23 this is
the this is the guy right this is the
guy so he's gonna he's gonna lead the
team and I just love Brian Cox and I
want to see him scream more at the floor
at all of them I think we talked about
this on another show but I just want the
succession music to play whatever he's
out there yeah all right well these are
five I would say unexpected teams four
for me who you know maybe I'm a little
more married to the car at the cartoon I
think is my problem here but I love this
we've got some very exciting team so
just to recap we've got on em T's tMT's
team negasonic teenage warhead
Quicksilver Colossus Jubilee and Dazzler
so this is a young skewing team with a
lot of a lot of young emotional angsty
teenagers figured girl power we have a
lot of girl power so Ashley you have
Nightcrawler blink Darwin bolt and
Psylocke this is a supercharged team
you've got teleporters you've got
electro fires you've got you've got a
man who literally can absorb anything
right and and it can't be killed except
for that he was killed for some reason
except by Kevin Bacon
Oh me but that's true of all of us when
our time comes and true it's trimming
for all of us Kevin Bacon will be there
to usher us across the river Styx
you've got what I like to call the
powerhouses you've got Wolverine you've
got that pool you've got Storm Omega
mutants abound on this x-23 so a little
father-son father-daughter combo and
then William Stryker for some reason
which I got the expendables minor the
old-timers I've just come back together
and they had this little girl with them
and just like Twitter decide by voting
on which of these teams they like the
best in Twitter poll so for now I'm
going to take the coward's way out and
award each of you a tensile Tom Tommy
separately show me how they arrived to
you guys what ship from the Star Trek
universe oh one of two potential entity
and I got this is the first appearance
of yeah which is I love Casey Jones
actually fun facts speaking of Casey
Jones I actually named somebody's baby
Casey Jones like bij like literally no
joke like her last name was Jones like
what just name your baby Casey it's your
wife have a baby male under perfect so
you know sparkle box for you oh my just
a boring old Sparkle book boring there I
think about really smart Lex in the
Bill's Eric Eric Sapru Ville is all
that's ever mattered to me let's see
here
not today this is the Internet that
sound of crippling desperation that you
hear coming from me means that it's time
for rogue questions questions coming
your way first of all a public service
announcement with viral this week with a
hockey mask Jason Voorhees imploring
people to wear a mask well in public
what fictional character has the easiest
time following CDC's guidelines that's
easy
okay Darth Vader oh my dude is already
freakin masked up all the time he's a
man he's hooked up to a ventilator
inside of him that's yeah I was going to
say Ripley from alien who had they
listened to her and not violated the
rules of quarantine on the Nostromo we
wouldn't had any problem yes okay so
going back to the x-men universe I'm
gonna say Logan and Laura because as
people with regenerative healing factors
they know the pain of dying so they
don't want to have to do that again
unless it's a battle thank you for
reminding us how fragile life is Kevin
Bacon will be coming for all of us
eventually question do Hasbro's coming
out with a poppet toy in the form of
baby Yoda where you punch and twist the
little guy what what baby he oughta
version of another classic toy would be
even more inappropriate I mean how is it
anything but Tickle Me Elmo because Yoda
is a muppet and Elmo's a muppet so
Tickle Me Baby Yuda
I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to go
with a baby Yoda magic 8-ball like maybe
Oh No
when will my parents love me shaken
violently my parents love me baby I was
gonna say a baby Yoda buddy doll from
the child's play series they just look
over in the chair it's not there anymore
and it chases you around the house of
the knife yes and it kills you a
possessed very inappropriate possessed
doll is if you had possessed ow
congratulations but if you had shaking
baby Yoda violently to get answers would
win a Tinseltown Tommy alright now last
but not least Anne Hathaway said in an
interview this week that Christopher
Nolan doesn't allow any chairs on his
sets so people never stop working mr.
Nolan I'm Michael Caine and I'm 89 years
right now no you may not take a seat
first of all it's Anne Hathaway ever
gonna work again because people I mean
people must be terrified now on a set
around here anyway
in your best Batman Joker or burn voice
give me an impression of that character
asking for a place to sit down so really
any Nolan verse person asking to take a
seat other sets vocals reckoning okay
very good very good who's next
good axe hi I'm Rachel Dawes I'm the
generic white lady who was recast
halfway through the trilogy and nobody
noticed you're gonna tell me that I'm
beautiful and as a result I deserve to
sit down in a chair
don't call me Karen
I believe I believe Rachel sitting in a
chair was her undoing in the end was it
not nobody nobody went for the paint
with all excellent but only one
mentioned the specificity of leg cramps
so Eric I reward your bein a Tinseltown
Tommy so correct me how many how many
wrote how many Tinseltown toppings do
you each have give me keeping track four
I have four Ashley I have four hey guys
you know what I went back and looked at
my judges score tired card and someone
was being a little modest because I have
empty as our winner at five
Tommy Tinseltown pictures portraits so
our winner today is as my as I am the
victor of this episode I want you all to
reveal to the world what your guilty
pleasure movie of choice is
[Laughter]
you know I can't even remember the name
of this movie but it's it's a romantic
comedy starring Deadpool himself Ryan
Reynolds where he tells the story
Definitely Maybe where he tells his
daughter oh the story of how he met her
mother but they don't tell you which one
of the three women he's talking about is
actually her mother until the very end
I've watched that movie that I could not
name the title of because then I may be
buried with shame probably about 15
times I used to put it on before bed
something to you like a warm glass of
milk soothe me into my slumber for the
evening so Definitely Maybe is
absolutely I'm putting that on the list
my choice well I'm one of those people
who I don't believe in guilty pleasures
like I'll own up to the things that I
like that are terrible I watched five
seasons of Teen Wolf and I loved it it's
not a good show eight like I definitely
dropped off before it ended if we're
looking for movies I really love the
Little Mermaid - it's not good it
doesn't function as a sequel at all but
I really like it I think there's a
Little Mermaid shoot I think there's
three there's three yeah there's a trip
Disney directed DVD market it was like
crazy of the early odds my friend all
right mr. boss
well my guilty pleasure TV show is the
MTV show and even max are married it's
just a fact
yes yes that's my guilty pleasure movie
is the film I've seen probably three or
four times I can't get enough of it
frickin love that movie
that's it for rogue theory we made it I
am no longer wet from the shower I'm now
wet from the nerdy sweatiness that we
have we have generated with all of this
information thank you so much let's
thank our guests for joining us miss
Ashley V Robinson thank you so much
thank you
social media handles that will be
displayed below I'm certain how about
another hand for our winner mg
congratulations
last but not least he's like a father
brother and dream boyfriend for me all
in one mr. Eric Voss thank you all for
joining us follow us on Twitter at new
rockstars I'm your host Tommy Bechtold
this will for sure be the last time I do
this I love you all very much have a
good night go Bills
[Music]